quickly about that journal Jasper in the
movie uh the real Jasper in real life he
was a PA on our movie oh and uh he did
all the drawings in those journals so oh
really they weren't Nick's drawings but
they were just how old is he now he's uh
63 years old no I'm
kidding he's uh like 24 or something
yeah and um you know
you you don't want to like creep them
out in any way it didn't feel like it
was a biopic um and
uh it's also kind of was like lens of
the role I felt like just find the
humanity in the guy don't try and play a
drug addict in any way that felt like
naive or self- serving or something so
uh um I think the biggest gift I got
from Nick and i' I've heard Steve say a
similar thing about David is was kind of
like licensed to go and like like go
make this thing and and and um and
without uh like a stringent or something
like that